This November, Captain Marvel is going to
get pretty dark.
Marvel Comics recently announced a story arc
entitled "The Last Avenger," which will run
in the pages of Captain Marvel beginning with
issue #12.
The arc will find Carol Danvers hunting down
her fellow Avengers, and at least one of them
will die by her hand early in the proceedings.
The official synopsis for the arc offers no
explanation other than to say that annihilating
the Avengers will be a pretty big deal:
"Captain Marvel has fought off alien hordes.
Rescued X-Men.
Punched Thanos in the face.
Literally saved the world.
She now faces her greatest challenge: kill
the Avengers.
Has one of the world’s most powerful heroes
gone dark?
But why?
And what does this mean for Carol...for the
world?
Life on Earth will never be the same."
"Wait til you see this next one.
Everybody dies!"
"DUDE!
Maybe it won't get that bad, but as to why
she would be forced to turn against her teammates,
and even go so far as to execute one or more
of them, we can only guess.
It wouldn't be the first time, either; Marvel
fans know that Captain Marvel was forced to
fight her fellow heroes during the events
of Civil War 2.
The arc comes courtesy of writer Kelly Thompson,
who has worked on a number of Marvel titles
including A-Force, Hawkeye, Jessica Jones,
and West Coast Avengers.
Thompson has been in charge of Captain Marvel
since the title's relaunch earlier this year,
and while she's had an awesome run, she's
the first to admit that she hasn't exactly
conditioned readers to expect the kind of
mega-bomb she intends to drop on them with
issue #12.
Speaking with Comicbook.com, Thompson said,
"Carol is an incredibly powerful character
and you can really push her to the furthest
edge, and you sort of need to in order to
keep things interesting, and that's what we're
trying to do with 'The Last Avenger.'
I think it's going to be a terrific Carol
story that really highlights her strengths
as a character, and maybe some weaknesses
as wel...It's a little risky but I'm excited.
I hope people love it."
We won't be able to crack open issue #12 until
it hits stands in November, but the synopsis
for issue #13 was recently released as well,
and it clues us in to the fact that it's going
to get pretty dark pretty fast, reading,
"One Avenger is dead at Captain Marvel’s
hand.
Who will be next?
And why?
What strange allegiance is driving Captain
Marvel to the darkest edge?"
Marvel has a long history of good characters
going bad, from the iconic X-Men story arc
"Dark Phoenix", which formed the basis for
this year's movie of the same name, to Spider-Man's
tangle with the symbiote which would eventually
become Venom.
But the idea of Captain Marvel turning on
her friends is a truly scary one, especially
since she's one of the most insanely powerful
characters in the entire Marvel universe.
Just like her Marvel Cinematic Universe counterpart,
she has strength and durability on par with
the Hulk, can discharge pure energy with perhaps
even more effectively than Thor, and can fly
faster than Iron Man.
She's a bit like all of the Avengers wrapped
into one, and if she's truly gotten it into
her head to wipe out Earth's Mightiest Heroes,
there might not be a heck of a lot anybody
can do to stop her.
Of course, Carol isn't just going to break
bad for no reason, and we can only guess as
to why she does.
Is it mind control?
A Captain Marvel from an alternate reality?
A really bad day?
An alien virus?
Or does this mysterious "allegiance" imply
that Carol isn't working on her own?
But who, and for what purpose?
Captain Marvel #12 hits stands and digital
platforms on November 20th, and that's when
the fun begins.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.